visiting Jordans Wadi Rum desert with a
Bedouin guy two hours off the great
desert highway leave the last signs of
life back at the village of Rome say no
thank you to the hotel and a luxury tent
with its beds cushions and plumbing
[Music]
you're Bedouins make camp at the base of
a layered desert bluff
[Music]
dress for the cool air wrap your head in
a checkered red and white kaffir
help with dinner grilling chicken and
eating with your hands
[Music]
have a glass of tea as sweet as candy
sitting on rugs and conversing until the
fire is gone the Bedouins have lived and
wandered this desert with their animal
herds thousands of years for the true
wilderness of Wadi Rum sleep outside the
vast vacancy of the world let your eyes
take in the midnight sky as the colossal
cosmos comes into focus
[Music]